des chaînes humaines comme celle là il y
en a eu un peu partout au québec tout ce
matin les parrains de ce mouvement je
protège mon école publique avait
d'ailleurs promis d'être nombreux à
dénoncer les compressions en éducation
à nous de bâtir la colère des parents se
fait entendre dans toutes les régions du
québec
en cette troisième journée de
manifestations depuis le printemps le
mouvement je protège mon école publique
a fait tache d'huile
les chiens humaines se sont multipliées
de montréal à québec dans l'ère moderne
on devrait plutôt se concentrer non pas
sur le fait que l'éducation est une
dépense mais plutôt très grand
investissement
partout des parents veulent se faire
entendre ils placent nos enfants si
comme des pions des grilles de calcul
des chefs
si on peut plus ne faut pas laisser
faire ça puis ça nous appartient de sur
les dix fois mais on conseille les
élèves parlent aussi sur ce vraiment
important d'être lapidés au monde
vraiment je protège mon école publique
le ministre ait pas l'école avec nos
enfants qui viennent passer une journée
avec nous puis là il verra que sa
demande de l'argent c'est tout ce qui a
été voté l'année dernière qui va devenir
effectif à partir de maintenant
notamment une réduction du nombre de
spécialistes dédiés aux élèves en
difficulté c'est exactement la même
enveloppe que l'an dernier
je comprends par ailleurs que des
commissions scolaires font des choix de
déployer ses services la dénonciation
pour cet économiste qui estime que le
gouvernement a plutôt investi dans
l'éducation entre 2003 et 2013
il y a un problème d'évaluation est ce
que l'argent qu'on ait mis en bonifiant
était une bonne chose
possiblement mais faudrait de savoir et
c'est là qu'il faut intervenir avec des
études transparence ont fait c'est le
secret la note propos et nous c'est pas
de juger qui a raison qui a tort mais de
dire que le constat qu'on tire en ce
moment à la rentrée dans l'est dans les
écoles c'est que les services ont
diminué le ministre françois blais qui
s'est fait reprocher d'être absents dans
les écoles a visité un établissement
tout neuf à lévis à l'abri des
manifestations kim de soi c'est la
question des enfants c'est l'utilisation
des enfants
ce matin pour tirer les slogans qu'ils
ne comprennent pas après la chaîne
humaine celle des dessins cri du coeur
des enfants nous assurant par an tout en
promettant de manifester encore le 1er
octobre ici anne louise despatie radio
canada montréal